salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
avez-vous déjà eu la chance d'observer
une aurore boréale bon en plein jour
c'est impossible et en région parisienne
c'est extrêmement rare mais plus au nord
en Norvège par exemple le phénomène est
beaucoup plus fréquent alors comment le
ciel peut-il s'illuminer ainsi et
comment mettre toutes les chances de son
côté pour un observer une suivez-moi je
vais vous éclairer
[Musique]
c'est beau
faute d'aurore boréale dans le ciel
parisien j'ai mis la main sur un
appareil qui reproduit le phénomène
moi
on fait ce qu'on peut bon je reprends et
d'abord une petite précision je parle
d'horreur boréale mais on devrait dire
aurore polaire car le phénomène se
produit au niveau des deux pôles nord et
suède et si dans l'hémisphère Nord on
parle d'aurore boréale du latin Boréas
qui signifie vent du nord dans
l'hémisphère sud on parle d'Aurore
australes
c'est ici au-dessus du cercle polaire
qu'on a le plus de chances d'assister à
ce spectacle précisément dans une zone
appelée ovale orale il s'agit d'une
bande d'une centaine de kilomètres qui
s'étend entre 65 et 75 degrés de
latitude nord pour voir une aurore
boréale enfin avoir une chance d'en
observer une il faut donc se rendre dans
le nord de la Scandinavie le nord de la
Russie en Islande au Groenland dans le
Grand Nord canadien ou en Alaska comme
je l'ai dit plus tôt le phénomène se
déroule aussi au pôle Sud mais dans une
zone beaucoup plus difficile d'accès si
les horreurs polaires n'ont jamais cessé
d'alimenter l'imagination des hommes
c'est parce qu'elles prennent parfois
des formes étranges comme ce visage
d'extraterrestre sur un cliché du
photographe Louis Bellay gourchi ces
jeux de lumière multicolores sont en
réalité liés
à l'activité du soleil
vous le savez notre étoile produit de la
lumière mais pas que elle est née aussi
un flot ininterrompu de particules
chargées électriquesment principalement
des protons et des électrons sous
l'effet des réactions qui se déroulent
dans le soleil c'est particules sont
éjectés propulsés dans l'espace à une
vitesse d'environ un million 300000 km
par heure elle forme ce que l'on appelle
le vent solaire s'il pénétrait dans
l'atmosphère se vend solaire empêcherait
toute vie ou presque car les particules
sont radioactives mais si ces
radioactifs c'est dangereux alors
non parce qu'à l'approche de la terre le
vent solaire se heurte au champ
magnétique terrestre il agit comme un
bouclier qui empêche ses particules
d'atteindre le plancher des vaches il
dévie environ 98% des particules qui
continuent leur voyage dans l'espace
toutefois un petit pourcentage arrive à
forcer le passage et à pénétrer le champ
magnétique
c'est particules se heurtent alors aux
lignes de champ qui forment de grands
arcs entre les pôles elle suit ses
lignes et pénètrent dans l'atmosphère à
ce niveau comme dans un entonnoir et là
c'est le feu d'artifice les protons et
les électrons bourré d'énergie entre en
collision avec les atomes qui composent
la haute atmosphère d'autres grains de
matière ceci s'excite à leur tour et
libère l'énergie qu'ils ont accumulé il
la libèrent sous forme de lumière ce
sont les fameuses aurores boréales
étaient vraiment surcron rien
mais non je te rassure les aurores
boréales ne présentent aucun danger pour
la santé elle se produise si haut dans
l'atmosphère qu'elles sont parfaitement
inoffensives pour ceux qui les observent
depuis le sol
elles forment de grands drapés de
lumière qui ont dû dans le ciel entre 80
et 300 km au-dessus de nos têtes elles
vont et viennent en fonction de la
puissance du vent solaire qui souffle
par rafale
c'est beau hein
si les aurores boréales nous fascinent
autant c'est qu'elles peuvent prendre
des couleurs très différentes vers rouge
bleu mauve et il y en a pour tous les
goûts ces couleurs varient en fonction
de la nature des atomes qui sont excités
on dit aussi qu'ils sont ionisés par les
particules solaires mais également en
fonction de leur altitude dans
l'atmosphère lorsque les particules
solaires
ionisent des atomes d'oxygène situé à
bas altitude un rayonnement de couleur
verte et émis comme ce rayonnement est
proche de nous et que le vert est une
couleur que notre œil perçoit facilement
les aurores vertes sont les plus
fréquentes mais lorsque les atomes
d'oxygène ionisés sont situés à plus de
200 km au dessus de nos têtes ils
émettent dans le rouge un rouge très
profond difficilement perceptible à
l’œil nu parfois l'horizon se remplit
d'un camaïeu mauve bleu rose ou blanc
ces couleurs sont émises par des atomes
d'azote situés proche de nous alors pour
assister à ce il faut attendre la nuit
car il est impossible de percevoir les
aurores boréales en pleine journée la
lumière émise par les atomes de
l'atmosphère n'est pas suffisamment
puissante enfin vous le savez au niveau
des pôles la nuit ne dure qu'une partie
de l'année il faut donc choisir la bonne
saison pour s'y rendre
dans l'hémisphère nord la bonne période
se situe entre novembre et mars les
nuits sont très sombres et très longues
elles dure 20 heures à la fin du mois de
décembre c'est ce qu'on appelle la nuit
polaire mais les chasseurs d'Aurore
boréales préfèrent les mois de janvier
et de février à cette époque de l'année
il ne neige quasiment pas le ciel est
donc bien dégagé il est aussi préférable
de choisir les périodes dites de
nouvelles lunes ou de lune noire ces
jours-là la Lune est cachée l'obscurité
est alors maximale et les aurores sont
plus visibles le clou du spectacle se
situe généralement entre 8h du soir et
1h du matin mais attention les aurores
boréales ne sont visibles que quelques
instants heureusement elles peuvent
revenir très vite avec un peu de chance
le spectacle peut se prolonger durant
plusieurs heures le lieu idéal se
situerait au nord de la Norvège sur
l'archipel du valbard si vous souhaitez
vous y rendre prévoyez des moufles et
une
les températures peuvent descendre
jusqu'à moins 30 degrés
un Français que tout le monde connaît a
dénicher un lieu beaucoup plus incongru
pour photographier les aurores boréales
Thomas Pesquet regardez ces images le
spationaute les a immortalisés depuis la
station spatiale internationale on peut
voir très nettement les arcs Ororo vert
ondulés au-dessus de la terre en Norvège
il fait trop froid dans l'espace j'irai
jamais j'ai aucune chance de voir une
horreur boréale moi c'est vrai c'est
très rare mais ça peut arriver dans la
nuit du 25 janvier 1938 une aurore
boréale à embraser le ciel parisien
alors comment est-ce possible et bien il
arrive parfois que les flux de
particules émis par le soleil soit si
violent que le vent solaire vire à la
tempête à l'approche de la terre cette
tempête déforme les lignes du champ
magnétique la zone dans laquelle les
particules solaires entre en contact
avec l'atmosphère s'agrandit permettant
aux particules de montrer jusqu'aux
tropiques
cette tempête solaire peuvent également
créer des orages magnétiques capables de
perturber les réseaux électriques et
internet sur une bonne partie du globe
par alors de blackout mais rien à voir
avec celui que l'on redoute en ce moment
qui lui est lié à un manque
d'électricité si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur ce phénomène de blackout lié
aux tempêtes solaires j'ai fait une
vidéo sur le sujet vous pouvez la
consulter en cliquant ici j'ai explique
que le soleil entre dans une phase
d'activité maximale tous les 11 ans en
moyenne les tempêtes solaires sont alors
plus fréquentes et les aurores boréales
plus intenses le prochain pic d'activité
est prévu pour 2025 et à mon avis comme
d'habitude de nombreux Japonais feront
le voyage jusqu'au Grand Nord selon une
légende tenace au pays du soleil levant
faire l'amour après avoir observé une
aurore boréale augmenterait les chances
d'avoir un enfant
allez on en profite une dernière fois
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout j'espère qu'elle vous a
donné envie d'enfiler vos moufles et vos
doudounes et de vous rendre dans le
cercle polaire pour admirer une vraie
horreur boréale allez à très bientôt
chers épicurieuses et épicurer
[Musique]